[Music]
performer Jourdan Fisher just dropped a
brand-new song but he's already a smash
hit on dance marquee talented kid man
this guy couldn't dance he can sing
Jordan and Lindsey are at the top of the
leaderboard with the highest score of
the season and probably still join the
celebration week's a big one yes bring
it down limping you're doing a Foxtrot -
Jordan song from mallanna he did a
version of your welcome with lin-manuel
Miranda Disney week must have some
meetings they just think the constant
for Jordan Fischer for me is that I am a
massive fan of Disney of Peter Pan
tattooed in my arm oh yeah yeah I am
thrilled about the knife because it's
just gonna be a bunch of nostalgia you
guys don't have any days off any
injuries so far anything can happen we
both have been sick I was a gymnast for
a long time most gym is for a decade and
I have destroyed my hips I have
tendinitis in both of my Kiwis I've got
a bad right knee I've got a bad right
shoulder I've got it's it's a lot but
you wouldn't be able to tell by the way
this 23 year olds dancing in this just
released music video for his song mess I
cannot believe you have all those
injuries you cannot tell I'm shot good
we try to hide them yeah you shouldn't
see me get out of my car it's not that's
not I'm sorry but that's proof right
there Dancing with the Stars is not easy
young kid like that in great shape when
he's still struggling it's funny cuz you
told me you had no issues when you do no
none at all none
you